in a moment i will ask you a puzzle and
it's a pretty hard puzzle actually but
before i do i want to lead with a
spoiler which is the fact that the way
we're going to solve this involves the
use of complex numbers and once you hear
it you will agree that that seems absurd
given that the puzzle is going to be
purely a discrete question it only asks
about whole numbers and their sums
there's not a width of the imaginary or
even continuity anywhere on the horizon
it's certainly not the only time that
complex numbers are unreasonably useful
for discrete math to borrow a phrase the
more famous example that i could bring
up would be how the modern way that
mathematicians understand prime numbers
you know questions about how they're
distributed their density at certain
regions things like that well it
involves studying specially designed
functions whose inputs and outputs are
complex numbers some of you may know
that this is what the famous riemann
hypothesis is all about basically
there's a specially designed function
and on the face of it it looks unrelated
to the discrete world of primes it's
smooth it's complex valued but under the
hood it encodes all of the information
that you could ever want about those
discrete prime numbers and most
importantly certain questions about
primes are easier to answer by analyzing
this function than they would be by
directly analyzing the primes themselves
of course our puzzle which i promise
i'll share in just a moment is a lot
more innocent than the riemann
hypothesis it's a toy problem but at the
end of the video i'll share how the
techniques that we use to solve it the
real reason that we're here are actually
pretty similar in spirit to the setup
that leads to the riemann hypothesis and
the prime number theorem and that whole
circle of thoughts around it
[Music]
our puzzle for today comes from this
book here by t2 and rescue and zooming
fun it's basically a collection of
problems used in training the usa team
for the international math olympiad and
if we turn to chapter 2 advanced
problems problem number 10 asks this
seemingly innocent question
find the number of subsets of the set
one up to two thousand the sum of whose
elements is divisible by five
okay so that might take a little bit of
a moment to parse for example something
like the set three one four that would
be a subset all of its elements are also
elements in the big set
and its sum three plus one plus four is
eight so that wouldn't be considered
that's not in our count whereas
something like the set two three five
also a subset has a sum of ten that is
divisible by five so it's one that we
wanna count
the preview animation that i had at the
start is essentially a brute force
program trying to answer this question
it will iterate through all of the
different possible subsets finding the
sum of each one along the way and it
increments a counter each time that it
finds a multiple of five
and you know what a nice warm-up
question here would be to pause and
think about how many total subsets are
there overall forget this multiple of
five stuff how long will it take for
this program to terminate
many of you may know the answer is 2 to
the power 2 000. the basic idea there is
that when you're constructing a subset
you have 2 000 different binary choices
you can make do you include an element
or do not and all of those choices are
independent of each other so the total
number of choices you have in
constructing a subset is 2 times 2 times
2 times 2 on and on 2 000 times
and thinking about our program that is a
monstrously huge number so even if we
gave this brute-forcing approach all the
time in the universe with all the
physical resources the universe could
conceivably provide
it wouldn't even come close it wouldn't
scratch the surface obviously we have to
be a lot cleverer than that and if you
were to just guess what the answer
should be make a rough approximation
you'd probably guess you know it should
be around a fifth of all the total
subsets there's probably a roughly even
distribution of all these sums mod five
and yes that is true that's a decent
approximation but the heart of the
question the real challenge here is to
get a precise answer this can't be the
actual answer since it's not an integer
but is the true answer a little bit more
or a little bit less or maybe it's a lot
more or a lot less what tactics could
you possibly use to figure out that
error
to be clear this lesson is definitely
much more about the journey than the
destination will you ever need to filter
and count subsets in this way almost
certainly not i wouldn't expect so but
toy problem or not it is a legitimately
challenging question and navigating that
challenge develops skills that are
relevant to other sorts of challenging
questions for you and me there are at
least two very surprising and very
beautiful twists and turns that the
solution i'd like to share with you
takes i've already tipped my hand that
complex numbers will make a surprise
appearance but before we even get to
that there is another strange turn which
is arguably even weirder and even more
unexpected
to set the stage though let's just get
our bearings with the puzzle and do what
all good problem solvers should do and
start with a simpler example maybe just
trying it with the set one two three
four five
if you were solving this problem with
pencil and paper you know you're one of
these kids training for the imo it's not
a bad idea to simply list out all two to
the five subsets it's only 32 it's not
that many
there's different ways that you might
want to organize all of these in your
mind but since the thing that we care
about is their sum the natural thing to
do would be to go through all of them
one by one and compute those sums over
here just doing it on youtube i've got a
computer so i'll cheat a little and show
what all their sums are i'll also cheat
a little bit and rearrange all of these
organizing them suggestively into
collections that all have the same sum
for instance there are three distinct
subsets that add up to six and they'll
all sit in this little box and the three
subsets adding up to 10 will all live in
this little box
and all in all the ones that we care
about the subsets with a sum divisible
by five have been put over here on the
left and it looks like there's a total
of eight of them
oh and by the way i should say we are
counting the empty set we consider it
sum to be zero and we consider that to
be a multiple of five by the end i hope
you'll agree all of those are abundantly
natural choices to make
take a moment to compare this answer to
what you might expect heuristically out
of all 32 total subsets a fifth of that
would have been 6.4 so at least in the
small example the true answer is a
little bit bigger than that that's maybe
something you want to talk in the back
of your mind
okay and this is the part of the video
where i'll be honest with you i've no
idea how to motivate it personally i
like it when math feels like something
you could have discovered yourself and
if you and i were sitting down together
solving this problem i think there's all
sorts of natural steps that you might
take maybe you try to understand if
there's some sort of structure to the
subsets or you play around with how
these sums are distributed mod 5 at many
different iterations for other small
examples and from that maybe you try to
eke out some kind of proof by induction
when i shared an early version of this
lesson with some patrons people brought
up some nice linear algebra approaches
all those are well and good nothing
wrong with those but instead my goal
here is to teach you about something
called a generating function and it's
one of those tactics where after the
fact you can think okay yeah i get that
this works but how on earth would you
have thought of that
honestly i don't know there's a time in
your life before you understand
generating functions and a time after
and i can't think of anything that
connects them other than a leap of faith
i'm going to ask you to consider the
polynomial 1 plus x times 1 plus x
squared
times 1 plus x cubed times 1 plus x to
the fourth times 1 plus x to the fifth
now i know you could rightfully ask
where does this come from what do
polynomials have to do with things what
is the variable x even supposed to
represent right now
and essentially x is purely a symbol the
only reason that we've written a
polynomial here is that the act of
algebraically expanding it is going to
completely mirror the act of
constructing subsets and importantly
this grouping that we want where subsets
with the same sum are all bunched
together kind of happens automatically
when you do this and let me show you
what i mean
when you expand out this expression
basically comes down to making five
binary choices which term from each
parenthetical do you choose
if you choose the one from each of those
parentheticals that will correspond to
the empty set where we don't choose any
of the elements
whereas if i choose the x to the one
term and then once from everything else
that will correspond to the singleton
set that just contains the number one
similarly if i choose the x squared term
but ones from everything else that
corresponds to the set just containing
two just choosing the x cubed term
corresponds to the set just containing
the number three
but interestingly notice what happens if
i choose the x to the one term and the x
squared term and then ones from
everything else
this corresponds to the choice of the
subset that has one and two and nothing
from everything else but in the
polynomial the way it expands looks like
x cubed so we have two different x cubed
terms each of which came from a subset
whose sum was three
and honestly the pattern that i'm going
for here is one that's probably easiest
if you just take the time to pause and
think through for yourself what happens
when you expand everything here
essentially every possible subset
corresponds to one of the terms in this
expansion and then the critical point is
that the exponent in the term that you
get from that expansion equals the sum
of that corresponding subset kind of
confusing when you say it out loud but
again if you just kind of think it
through yourself i think you can see
what i mean for example when all of the
dust settles and we collect all 32 terms
here three of those terms are x to the
tenth and each of those came from a
choice of elements whose sum was equal
to ten
now normally when we write a polynomial
we collect together all like terms so
instead of having three copies of x to
the tenth we would just see the
coefficient 3 in front of x to the 10th
so each of these coefficients is a way
of encoding the number of subsets with a
particular sum
so this like i said at the start is an
example of something called a generating
function where the idea is if you have
some question with an answer associated
with each positive integer so in our
case how many subsets add up to a
particular value when you construct a
polynomial whose coefficients correspond
to the answers to that question
you can get a surprising amount of
insight from your original question by
mathematically manipulating and
analyzing the properties of this
polynomial there are tons and tons of
examples of generating functions but
just to bring up one other one which is
especially fun you can use the same idea
to study fibonacci numbers so all the
coefficients of this polynomial will be
fibonacci numbers and in this case it's
an infinite polynomial so i should
really be calling it a power series
i won't fully explain the details here
but i will leave them up on the screen
for anyone who's curious the basic idea
is that the rule that's used to define
fibonacci numbers each one being the sum
of the previous two can be expressed as
an equation in terms of this function
that equation in turn lets you write
that function in an alternate form and
then and here's most of the details i'm
skipping over if you manipulate that you
know throw in a little partial fraction
decomposition here a little bit of
geometric series power expansion there
you can get yourself an exact closed
form expression for each individual
fibonacci number which is really cool
i mentioned this really just to show the
tip of the iceberg of the fact that this
idea of a generating function goes way
way beyond our particular example
now in our particular problem if we
extend from the simple example with just
one two three four five to the big
example with all the numbers up to two
thousand
our corresponding generating function
involves these two thousand different
binomial terms you know one plus x one
plus x squared on and on up to one plus
x to the two
and the idea is that if you were to
expand this the coefficients tell us all
the information we want now it would be
insane to actually expand it but it is
helpful to keep in the back of your mind
in principle what that would look like
for example in principle if you expanded
it you would find that the coefficient
in front of the x to the 25th term
happens to be 142
and this corresponds to the fact that
there are 142 distinct subsets that have
a sum of 25.
so the art of analyzing a generating
function here will be to deduce facts
about these coefficients without
actually expanding the
expression so moving forward i'm just
going to write this expansion more
abstractly just a sum from n equals 0 up
to capital n where c sub n tells us the
coefficients that we don't know all of
that starts off as a black box to us and
moving forward we're going to start
treating this as an actual function
something where we plug in x we see what
the output is and then we ask what does
that tell us about the coefficients for
example a very easy input would be to
plug in something like x equals 0. in
that case importantly we know how to
evaluate it using the factored form
above if you plug in x equals 0 for
everything all of the terms look like 1
so the answer is 1. and in the expanded
form all of those terms involving an x
will get killed they go to 0 leaving us
just with the first term c sub 0.
now in this case that doesn't really
tell us anything all that exciting it
essentially translates to saying there
is a single empty set but we're just
getting our feet wet
as the next example take a moment to
think about evaluating f at one
this is something we can do with the
expression we know when you plug in one
for all of these x's every term looks
like a two so in total we get two
multiplied by itself two thousand times
on the other hand in the expanded
expression if you plug in x equals one
all of these powers of x go to 1 so
we're essentially adding up all of the
coefficients which is pretty cool when
you think about it just by evaluating
the function at a single number we can
deduce what the sum of all of the
coefficients are
now again in our particular example it's
not all that exciting because we already
know what the sum of these coefficients
are
remember each coefficient counts how
many subsets have a certain sum and so
when you add them up we're just counting
all of the subsets which we know to be
two to the two thousand however i can
give you a genuinely new fact if i ask
you to evaluate this function at
negative 1. take a moment to think about
what that means
if you plug in negative 1 again we start
with the thing we know the factored
expression up top and here all you need
is to look at the first term when you
plug in x the first parenthetical goes
to zero so the whole expression has to
be zero but what does that tell you when
we apply it to the expanded expression
using all of the coefficients and in the
spirit of being as suggestive as
possible of the strange turns that this
solution takes i want you to really
visualize the various powers of negative
one in this expression in terms of
rotations the first term negative one to
the zero is just one which we'll picture
as a vector from zero to one then
negative one to the first power is just
negative one itself which i want you to
be thinking about as a 180 degree
rotation away from that last term then
when we take negative one squared that's
positive one again a 180 degree rotation
and in general each successive term here
looks like another rotation by 180
degrees algebraically what this
translates to is that we have an
oscillating sum between the even
coefficients and the odd coefficients
but keep the visual in the back of your
mind this expression is true for any
generating function but again for our
special generating function we know that
this value this alternating sum should
equal zero and the way you can interpret
that is that it's telling you there's an
equal balance between the even
coefficients and the odd coefficients
and remember maybe in the context of our
smaller example these coefficients are
encoding for us facts about subsets so
if there's an equal balance between all
those even coefficients and the odd
coefficients it's telling you that half
of all the subsets have an even sum and
half of them have an odd sum that's
probably what you would expect but it's
not obvious at first how you would show
that and with the generating function it
just kind of pops right out
and again to be suggestive of where
we're going let me rewrite this a little
bit by taking the last two things we
evaluated
add up those two and then divide by one
half
if you think about it this is a way of
filtering out all of the even
coefficients and killing all of the odd
coefficients so it becomes an especially
clean way to write the fact that the sum
of all of the even coefficients which
again in the back of your mind means the
total number of subsets with an even sum
will look like half of the total this is
needless to say tantalizingly close to
the actual question we want to answer
what we would like to do is find some
clever thing that we can do to the
function f some well-chosen numbers to
evaluate it on so that we get all the
coefficients corresponding to multiples
of five again thinking back to what
these coefficients encode for us that
will be answering our final question
that will be counting the total number
of subsets whose sum is divisible by
five
the trick to doing this is to generalize
what we just did where the successive
powers of the input were rotating back
and forth
but this time we don't want them to
rotate every other time we'd like them
to somehow rotate with a period of five
and to do that we extend into the
complex plane you see up there we can
find a value so that as we take
successive powers of it it will rotate
by a fifth of a turn giving us a process
with a frequency of five
and if you step back i know that it's
kind of absurd that i'm asking you to
think about complex numbers i mean we
started with a counting question it's
discrete math but hopefully it's not all
that wild
and again the reason that i'm drawing
things out to tee up the various strange
terms in the solution is that they're
actually not all that strange in the
broader scheme of math the trick we're
about to apply has a heavy resemblance
to many other instances of using complex
numbers to better understand discrete
questions of integers so the more it
feels like something that you could have
discovered yourself
the more it might actually be the case
that when you're working on some future
problem in this circle of thoughts you
will discover it yourself
to be specific the complex number that i
care about is one that i'm going to
label zeta and it sits a fifth of a turn
around the unit circle so its angle is
two pi fifths radians and its magnitude
is one
this means with the standard euler's
formula notation we would write that
number explicitly as e to the power 2 pi
i divided by 5. if you're not as
comfortable with that notation you could
think of it as something whose real part
is the cosine of 72 degrees 72 being a
fifth of a full turn and the imaginary
part is the sine of 72 degrees
but to be honest you don't actually need
to think about the explicit value
instead the important thing to focus on
is the property that powers of this
number have
for example when you square it because
its magnitude was one the magnitude of
its square is also one but it rotates a
fifth of a turn around the unit circle
so it now sits two-fifths of a turn
around
similarly when you raise it to the third
power you end up three-fifths of a turn
around raise it to the fourth power you
end up four-fifths of a turn and raise
it to the fifth power and you've gotten
all the way back around to one it's the
same thing as if you had raised it to
the zeroth power we get this cycling
every five terms that's the thing that
we care about
these numbers have a special name
they're called the fifth roots of unity
essentially because they solve the
equation z to the fifth equals one they
are fifth roots of the number one if you
just presented someone with this
equation they would probably say the
answer is clearly z equals one but the
idea is that there are four other
answers in the complex plane four other
numbers where when you raise them to the
fifth you get one and considering them
as a collective is often quite useful
remember that equation it'll come back
for us a little bit later
so in analogy with what we did earlier
where we added together f of one and f
of negative one to get this cancellation
among the odd terms what we're going to
do is evaluate f at all five of these
numbers and then add them together and
hopefully we get some cancellation that
might seem kind of complicated but let's
just take a super simple example like
the case where f of x is simply equal to
x in that case when we add up these five
terms we're just adding up the roots of
unity themselves zeta to the zero plus
zeta to the one on and on up to zeta to
the fourth when you add complex numbers
uh you can think of it like vector
addition with the tip to the tail
so zeta to the zero plus zeta will look
like this and then if i add on zeta
squared bringing the tail of that vector
to the tip of the last one we get this
then similarly if i bring the tail of
zeta cubed over to the tip of that one
and then do likewise for zeta to the
fourth you'll see how the overall sum
actually loops back to be zero another
way to think about this is that all five
of these terms are evenly balanced
around the number zero their center of
mass is at the origin
now it's helpful to think about a
slightly less trivial example if f of x
was x squared
so when you square zeta to the zero it
stays zeta to the zero this is just a
fancy way of saying the number one when
you square zeta you get zeta squared
itself so you might imagine this dot up
here moving over to the zeta squared dot
when we do it
theta squared moves to zeta to the
fourth so you might imagine this dot
moving over to zeta to the fourth
zero cubed moves to zeta to the sixth
which because we loop around every five
times is the same thing as zeta to the
one so this dot will move up here
and finally zeta to the fourth squares
to give us theta to the eighth which
reduces to be the same as zeta cubed uh
which i might draw like this
that might seem a little confusing to
think about especially with all the
arrows i have drawn here but it's worth
thinking through at least once in your
life because the idea here is that when
we square this i go to all of these
different terms and i program them to
double the angle that they have
the overall effect is to just shuffle
those terms we get the same numbers but
written in a different order so their
sum is still going to be zero
similarly if you go through this
exercise with x cubed which i encourage
you to do and you follow around where
are each one of these dots going to end
up you'll be able to see that when we
cube these terms when we take each one
and we multiply the angle that it has by
three again we just shuffle them around
same terms listed in a different order
unsurprisingly the same thing happens if
our function was x to the fourth
but critically where things change is if
we consider the function x to the fifth
in that case when you raise zeta to the
fifth power by definition it goes to one
similarly zeta squared raised to the
fifth power goes to one all of these go
to one they are the roots of unity this
is after all their whole purpose in life
so in this case when we apply the
function and add them all up instead of
going to zero and getting cancellation
we get a kind of constructive
interference all of them equal one so
their sum is equal to five so if you
step back and think about what all those
examples mean
essentially this expression is something
that will go to zero for powers of x
which are not divisible by five but it
goes to something non-zero for powers of
x which are divisible by 5 and that's
exactly the kind of filter that we're
looking for
if you're worried that our actual
function is much more complicated than a
simple power of x essentially things
play really nicely here because
everything is linear
if f is some massive polynomial and we
want to evaluate this big sum
you could sort of think of going column
by column
where each time you really are just
adding up powers of zeta and in most
cases all those powers cancel out with
each other and you get zero but when all
of those powers are multiples of five
they constructively interfere and
instead you get five times whatever the
corresponding coefficient is
deep in the weeds it's easy to forget
why we're here in the first place but
remember each one of those coefficients
tells us how many subsets add up to a
certain value and so what we want is to
add up all of the coefficients that are
multiples of five
and what we have right now is a way to
explicitly do that if we evaluate this
function on these five different routes
of unity which i know seems kind of
weird then all we have to do is divide
by five and it gives us the sum that we
want
that's really cool if you ask me we have
a question that's just about subsets
it's a discrete math problem and yet the
way that we can answer it is to evaluate
a crazy polynomial on some judiciously
chosen complex numbers the more math you
do the less crazy that seems cause
complex numbers have this bizarre
relationship with discrete math but it
really is wonderful there's no two ways
about it however some of you might
complain the only way that this is
useful is if we can actually evaluate
this wild expression on our polynomial
now remember the form of the polynomial
we know the one we're comfortable with
is the factored form where you have this
one plus x one plus x squared on and on
all the way up to one plus x to the two
thousand
everything up to this point is just
meaningless symbolic play pushing around
one part problem into another unless we
can actually roll up our sleeves and do
some honest calculation here this is the
final thrust in our argument so step
back take a deep breath it's actually
not as bad as you might think but let's
start just by thinking about how you
might evaluate just one of the roots of
unity that we need maybe zeta itself
so what that looks like is one plus zeta
times one plus zeta squared times one
plus a to cubed on and on except
importantly after those first five terms
everything starts repeating because
powers of zeta repeat the entire
expression up to 2000 is basically just
going to be a copy of this expression
400 times it still might seem hard to
evaluate this expression but it's way
easier than multiplying out 2 000
different terms a way you might
visualize this is that we're taking each
one of those roots of unity but
basically adding one we're shifting them
all to the right this picture actually
lends itself to a really nice geometric
intuition for the numerical answer that
we might expect the thing that we want
is the product of these five different
complex numbers these five yellow dots
and if you know a thing or two about
complex numbers since these come in
conjugate pairs all we really need is to
multiply the lengths of these five
yellow lines
for example that dot furthest to the
right corresponds to one plus zeta to
the fifth uh which in the diagram i'm
labeling as zeta to the zero plus one
but it doesn't matter in either case
they're both just fancy ways of writing
the number two next to that we have the
values one plus zeta and one plus zeta
to the fourth both of which have the
same magnitude the lengths of these
lines are the same and let's just give
that a name l one so we need to multiply
two different copies of that length l
one squared
similarly the remaining two values theta
squared plus one and zeta cubed plus one
they also have the same length and
they're a conjugate pair so let's just
call that length l2 so our product needs
to include two copies of that l2 if we
were just making a loose heuristic guess
you might notice that l1 is a length
that's something a little bit longer
than one and l2 is something a little
bit shorter than one so the final answer
here probably comes to something around
two ish we're not positive but something
in that ballpark to turn this into an
exact answer we could just expand out
the full expression it's honestly not
that bad there's only 32 different terms
okay you've hung with me for a long time
now and i know that it's getting to be a
lot but there's one final trick in this
whole argument that makes our last step
much simpler than you might think it
should be
and let's just recap to remind ourselves
of where we are so we started with this
question asking us count the number of
subsets of 1 up to 2 000 whose sum is
divisible by five we then constructed
this polynomial whose coefficients tell
us how many subsets have a particular
sum for each value n
so what we want is to add up every fifth
coefficient of that polynomial
then we saw how evaluating this
polynomial as a function on all of the
fifth roots of unity then adding them up
ends up giving us exactly this filter
that we want and here we're evaluating
just one of those terms f of zeta which
essentially comes down to a product of
five complex numbers as a super slick
way to actually evaluate that product
here's the final trick
remember i describe these numbers as
roots of unity they solve the equation z
to the fifth equals one another way to
think about that is that they are roots
of the polynomial
z to the fifth minus one
now what that means is we can factor the
polynomial z to the fifth minus one to
look like this where there's one factor
corresponding to each one of the roots
you take z minus each one of the roots
this expression is kind of magical when
you think about all of the crazy
cancellation that has to happen when you
expand it all out but it is true and
it's super useful for us right now
because the expression on the right hand
side looks almost identical to the thing
we need to evaluate up at the top here
it basically just has minus signs where
we wish there were plus signs
the trick is to plug in z equals
negative one
if you do that you essentially have the
negative of what we want so if you
multiply it by negative one notice how
the left hand side here which started
out as negative one minus one or
negative two that just becomes two
and then the right hand side turns into
the thing that we want to evaluate so
just as our geometric intuition earlier
might have suggested not only is the
answer around two the answer quite
magically turns out to be precisely two
that is actually super nice and very
lovely because it means this bigger
expression that we want to evaluate
where we're adding up f on all of the
different roots of unity we know its
value on the first root of unity it will
be 2 to the power 400. essentially
identical reasoning shows that its value
on the next three roots of unity is also
2 to the power 400 because remember when
you take powers of zeta squared or zeta
cubed you get the same list of numbers
they're just shuffled in a different
order
the only one that's different is when we
evaluate it as zeta to the zero but
theta to the zero is a fancy way of
saying the number one and we know how to
evaluate this at one that's one of the
easy things we did this earlier all of
these parentheticals turn into two so it
looks like taking two multiplied by
itself two thousand times
and so finally with that we have a
highly explicit honest answer to our
counting question to add up all of these
coefficients which are divisible by five
which remember is a way of counting how
many total subsets have a sum divisible
by five the answer is one-fifth of this
weird complex expression which we just
computed to be two to the two thousand
plus four different copies of two to the
four hundred
and here you might wanna do just a quick
sanity check on does this answer make
any sense
for example if you do it in the smaller
case with the set one two three four
five and you walk through all the same
reasoning that we just did it tells you
that the answer is one-fifth of two to
the fifth the total number of subsets
plus four times two to the one in this
case uh which is a fifth of 32 plus
eight which is eight and if you'll
remember when we explicitly looked at
them all that was in fact the answer
look this is a hard puzzle and when it's
worth putting in the time to solve a
hard problem it's also worth taking some
time to reflect on it what do you get
out of this what's the takeaway
now you could reflect on the answer
itself how the dominant part is indeed
one-fifth of all the total subsets like
we might have guessed and how this error
term came about from the not quite
destructive interference in a massive
combination of roots of unity
but again what makes this question
interesting is not the answer it's the
way that we solved it namely taking a
discrete sequence that we want to
understand and treating it as the
coefficients on a polynomial then
evaluating that polynomial on complex
values
both of those steps are probably highly
unexpected at the outset but both of
those steps relate to some very general
and powerful techniques that you'll find
elsewhere in math
for example at the top of the lesson i
promised that the technique that we
would use would be similar in spirit to
the way that primes are studied and the
set of ideas that leads up to the
vermont hypothesis and things like that
now this is a very beautiful topic
enough so that i think it seems a little
criminal to cram some kind of rushed
version into the end here the right
thing to do i think is to just make that
video i promised a while back about the
zeta function take the time do it right
but if you're curious and if you'll
allow me to throw some things up on the
screen without explaining them here's
the two or three sentence version of how
the two are parallel
just like our subsets puzzle the way
that riemann studied primes involved a
discrete sequence we want to understand
something carrying information about
prime numbers and then considering a
function whose coefficients are the
terms in that sequence
in that case it's not quite a polynomial
instead it's a related structure known
as a dirichlet series or directly series
depending on who you ask but it's the
same essential idea then the way to suss
out information about those coefficients
comes from studying how this function
behaves with you guessed it complex
valued inputs
the techniques in his case get a lot
more sophisticated after all riemann was
a pioneer in complex analysis but the
fact remains extending your domain
beyond real numbers like this offers you
the mathematician a lot more power in
making deductions about the coefficients
for some viewers this all might leave
the lingering question of
why exactly complex numbers are so
unreasonably useful in this way
it's a hard question to answer exactly
but if you think about our puzzle
everything we just did as soon as we
were in this situation where plugging in
different inputs revealed hidden
information about the coefficients
it's sort of like the more inputs you
can work with the better so you might as
well open yourself up to a richer space
of numbers like the complex plane
but there is a more specific intuition
that i want you to come away with here
in our puzzle the relevant fact that we
wanted the sum of every fifth
coefficient
was a kind of frequency question and the
real reason that complex numbers as
opposed to some other structure proved
to be useful for us is that we could
find a value so that successive products
have this cycling behavior this use of
values on the unit circle and roots of
unity in particular to suss out
frequency information is extremely
fruitful it is almost impossible to
overstate how helpful that idea is
just to give one out of thousands of
examples in the 1990s peter shore found
a way for quantum computers to factor
large numbers way way faster than
classical computers can and if you go in
and you look at the details of how what
we now call shore's algorithm works
the idea is essentially this the use of
roots of unity to detect a kind of
frequency information more generally
this is the core idea that underlies
fourier transforms and fourier series
and the infinite swell of topics that
follow from those
as to the topic of generating functions
themselves we've really only just
scratched the surface here and if you
want to learn more i highly recommend
this kind of hilariously named book
generating functionology by herbert wilf
and i'll also leave up a few fun puzzles
on the screen here for anyone who wants
to flex their muscles a bit with the
idea
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you